[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens
j'aimerais bien qu'il ya plus de tramway
comme
par exemple à rotterdam c'est génial
parce qu'il ya un pont et on peut
prendre soin la voiture soit le tramway
et votre sale en pense quoi ça va
[Musique]
présente on se retrouve à des pires
hamon s'était pas vu depuis longtemps
mais bon c'est cool et la terre en
indépendant je suis en freelance en ce
moment mettre un peu de beurre dans les
épinards kanoun à olemps voulait-il nous
paye c'est une vraie galère commet des
fautes il augmente cyril qui est a dit
quoi
opti augmente ton chroniqueur nos futurs
à les gens sont désagréables je peux pas
pas du bien quoi et votre elle en pense
quoi
mon frère ils aidèrent c'est qui ces
lits qui est venu le temps des
cathédrales break au nord
ok j'avoue c'est jean michel maire
depuis le début ça fait cinq ans que
c'est jean michel maire cette connerie
et frère qu'est ce que je pense des
transports en commun parisiens qui sont
cool bien desservi
il ya plein de ligne les gens sont plus
agréables que ce qu'on croit et votre
elle en pense quoi ça va mon frère les
transports alors t'en pense qu'on va
rien on poggi bouille have to l'aprem
laisse tomber c'est vrai que j'ai kane
un truc de fou là hein on la connaît tu
vois que j'ai jamais fait l'amour
tempête ida bien joué ah ouais bien
jouer les jeunes et jolies alors j'y
suis venu parce qu'on peut plus circuler
en voiture dans paris mais
l'inconvénient du vélib c'est que
paris est de plus en plus polluée et
quand vous êtes en vélo vous êtes
complètement asphyxiés par les bus qui
eux fonctionnent toujours au diesel et
votre elle en pense quoi
mon frère j'ai pas de faire des faux
jumeaux
bonjour alors les faux jumeaux en fait
il qu'un suis né le 23 à l'accouchement
difficile
ledit d'intermèdes amusant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]